Demasiado joven para la historia en el
pasado mundial de Rusia con 19 años fue
el goleador más joven de una final
mundialista después de Pelé este domingo
frente a Argentina Busca invadir otro
primado del Rey llevar a Francia a ser
la primera selección que suma títulos
consecutivos desde que Brasil de Pelé lo
hizo en 1962 todo esto ha pasado en
apenas 23 años de vida pero es que
mbappé va muy rápido pocos superan el
vértigo de sus desbordes hace tres años
alcanzó una velocidad máxima de 38
kilómetros por hora en un trecho de 30
metros un poco más rápido que el
promedio de usain bolt para imponer en
2009 el récord mundial de los 100 metros
planos en Qatar se ha convertido en el
más joven de todos los tiempos en llegar
a nueve goles en mundiales muchos de sus
anotaciones se deben a la visión
creadora de griezmann pero mbappé
acapara el foco hijo de una ex jugadora
de balonmano y un entrenador camerunés
mbappé creció en bondí un suburbio de
población mayoritariamente africana en
la periferia de París que hoy sueña que
su hijo favorito vuelva a levantar la
copa del mundo
y la pauli
él no olvida a veces cuando las cosas se
complican nos olvidamos de dónde venimos
pero no él él no es así
[Música]
Julian es la estrella emergente la
estrella de las Estrellas y la verdad
sea dicha Es la envidia del mundo este
domingo del otro lado del campo tendrá
su compañero del psg Lionel Messi pero
mbappé sólo verá en él un último
obstáculo camino a la gloria
[Aplausos]